what I want to do in this video is make
sure we understand the difference
between comparative advantage and
absolute advantage what we saw in the
last video is that Patti had a
comparative advantage in pilate's
relative to Charlie because her
opportunity cost of producing one plate
was lower than Charlie's opportunity
cost of producing a plate hers was
one-third of a cup
his was three cups so that's why it made
sense for her to specialize in plates
charlie on the other hand had a had a
comparative advantage in cups his
opportunity cost for producing a cup was
only a third of a plate while Paddy's
was three plates so that's why he
specialized in cups now we can't confuse
this with absolute advantage absolute
advantage in a given product just means
that you produce that you you are more
productive at that thing given the same
inputs and so if I were to just give you
this graph and you didn't know how many
workers Charlie or Pattie had and how
many inputs they're using to produce
either 30 cups in a day or 30 plates in
a day you actually could not make any
statement about absolute advantage but
if we assume that in all of these
scenarios they have the same number of
inputs so if we think about plates if we
say given let's say they each have one
employee maybe it's themselves and given
that well one input that or the same
number of inputs Pattie is able to
produce more plates than charlie
then it is true Pattie would have an
absolute advantage in plates and if
given the same number of inputs Charlie
is able to produce more cups than Pattie
then he would have an absolute advantage
in cups but it is not because of that
absolute advantage that he is
specializing it in fact we don't even
know what their inputs were it might be
that he doesn't have an absolute
advantage maybe charlie maybe Charlie
needs a hundred people to produce 30
cups while Pattie can produce ten cups
with one person
so in that case actually Pattie would
have an absolute advantage but it just
wouldn't be obvious from this right over
here but to make everything clear I want
to make a I want to do a scenario where
let's say Charlie improved his
productivity in some way and he actually
has the absolute advantage in both
products and still show that as long as
they have different comparative
advantage
is that it still makes sense for them to
specialize so let's let's do another
scenario so Charlie has improved
dramatically so let's draw our little
graph here so that's our cups axis and
this is still our plates axis cups and
plates and let me put some more markers
here 10 20 30 and 40 and 10 20 30 and 40
and let's still put patty let's assume
patty hasn't changed so this is her PPF
so that is Patty's PPF just like that
but let's say that Charlie has improved
dramatically and so Charlie's PPF looks
like this so this is Charlie's PPF now
looks like this so in a given day he can
produce and let's just assume that
they're using the same number of inputs
so using the same number of inputs in a
given day he can produce 40 cups when
patty can only produce 10 so he has the
absolute advantage in cups or in the
same given day using the same inputs he
could produce 40 plates while patty can
only produce 30 so now charlie all of a
sudden has an absolute advantage in both
in both products but we'll see it still
makes sense for them to specialize
because they have different comparative
advantages they have different
opportunity costs so let's let's figure
this out so we have all the same numbers
for Patty actually let me let me copy
and paste Patty's numbers right over
here actually we have access to our
numbers right over here so I don't even
have to copy and paste it but let's
think of Charlie's new numbers now so
this is the PPF for charlie so this is
our new PPF for charlie maybe he did
some investment or R&D to get him this
new awesome productive PBF so he's
expanded his PPF so what is his what is
his opportunity cost so say like he say
he's sitting here what is his
opportunity cost of producing so he's
producing 40 cups what would be his
opportunity cost of producing 40 plates
well to produce those 40 plates he would
have to give up those 40 cups so this
opportunity cost of 40 plates
is equal to 40 cups or you divide both
sides by 40 his opportunity cost for one
plate one plate is equal to one cup and
this is this makes math very easy his
opportunity cost for one cup is one cup
is equal to is equal to one plate now
given this new reality so we've already
established Charlie has an absolute
advantage in both using the same inputs
he can do more of either of them and
remember when you talk about absolute
advantage you have to think about the
amount of inputs you use who's more
productive in that way but let's think
about comparative advantage if we think
about plates who has a lower opportunity
cost for producing a plate patty hasn't
changed her opportunity cost for to
producing a plate is 1/3 of a cup
Charlie's opportunity cost for producing
a plate has improved but it's still it's
still worse than Patty's he has to spend
1 cup to make a plate she only has to
give up 1/3 of a cup to make a plate so
patty still has a comparative advantage
in plates and if we look at the
comparative advantage or if we look at
the opportunity cost in cups the
opportunity cost for Charlie to make one
cup is one plate so it actually it's
actually a little bit it's actually it's
actually a little bit worse than it was
before but that's as we'll see that it
ends up being a good thing he's just
overall more productive but his
opportunity cost his opportunity cost
for one cup he's giving up one plate now
and before he was producing 1/3 of a
plate and that's because in the other
scenario he was kind of more he was more
one-sided I guess is one way to say it
but his opportunity cost for producing a
cup is still is still cheaper than
Patty's her cost of producing a cup is
three plates or opportunity cost while
his is only one plate so he still has
the comparative advantage he still has
the comparative advantage in cups so
Charlie should still specialize in cups
specialize specialize in cups and patty
should still specialize in plates and to
show that they can still get an outcome
that is beyond even Charlie's production
possibilities frontier let's think about
how they could trade so Charlie is going
to specialize in cups he's going to sit
right over
they're producing 40 cups a day and
Patty is going to specialize she is
going to specialize in plates and she's
gonna sit right there
and produce let me do some different
color I don't use his color and she's
gonna sit right over there and produce
30 plates a day so how could they trade
for mutual benefit well any trade that
is better than their assuming that they
don't want to have only plates or they
don't only want to have cups any trade
that is cheaper than their opportunity
cost will be a good one so for example
Pat is sitting here producing only
plates her opportunity cost for a cup is
three plates her opportunity cost for
cup is three plates so she would be
willing to trade anything less than
three plates for a cup assuming that she
wants it because if she had to make the
cups herself she would have to give up
three plates so let's say let's say that
she she'd be willing to trade so patty
patty patty would be willing willing to
trade one cup I started one plate
actually let me write this is she's be
willing to write two plates two plates
for one cup she'd be willing to trade
that because if she had to if she had to
if she had to make the cups herself she
would have to give up three plates for
one cup so she's willing to trade two
plates for one cup and let's see if
Charlie would be willing to trade two
plates for one cup so he has all of
these cups how many cups does he have to
give away for a plate well he has to
give away one cup for a plate now he
would have to give away one cup for two
plates or really he would have to give
up half a cup for a plate either way
this is better than his opportunity cost
of of of trying to get that incremental
plate so he would be willing to do this
to two plates for one cup he'd be
willing to do one cup for two plates and
to see how that would improve he could
trade so he could have 40 right here 40
cups or he could trade one of them away
he could trade one of them away actually
let's let's do a scenario where he
trades he trades ten of the cups away so
he trades ten of the cups away so now he
only has 20 cups but for those 20 cups
he traded away
for those 20 cups actually that's a bad
example because Patty won't have enough
cups so let's say he trades away 10 cups
let's say he trades away 10 cups for
those 10 cups so let's get the scenario
so Charlie Charlie trades trades 10 cups
10 cups for 20 for 20 plates so now he
traded 10 cups and he gets 20 plates so
now he'll end up at this scenario right
over here which was beyond it was
unattainable when he was working by
himself when he didn't specialize and
get these gig gains from trade so this
is a good scenario for him he's able to
get outcomes that he otherwise would not
have been able to get he could depending
on how he trades he could get outcomes
on on that wall up to a certain point up
to a certain point because Patti only
has 20 Patti only has 30 cups so he can
only get about he can only at best he
could take all of Paddy's cups so he
could get something along that line over
there but if we look at the same
scenario paddy traded to 20 plates for
ten cups how does where does that put
her so she traded 20 plates so she's
down to ten plates but she got ten cups
so that put her right over here once
again beyond her production
possibilities frontier so this would
look like a pretty good situation for
patty as well